where's my lid
you see the lid of course i need that
lid it's a collection item
it needs the lipstick why'd you have a
mug with no liquid in it yeah
why are you asking for a little why are
you asking for a lid if you're not gonna
drink coffee
i need this guy to be nice and cool i do
actually but also you know i think of
this mag as a collector's pieces should
the viewers who bought it and it should
always have the lid on it yeah but
there's yeah you don't have like santa
claus without the red suit on you know
what i mean like you don't have the
trash taste mug without the lid yeah but
you just got it on you you have like a
coffee cup right there and you have like
a mustache that's unused
now get this out of here why is there a
little on the floor did you drink the
coffee not out of the trash taste mug
i don't like transferring liquids from
like fake trash taste fan
i also want my trash taste like
transferring liquids
i i like i like the the mug what is this
man's mug look at this [ __ ] what did you
how did you get this [ __ ] on you know
what i've been drinking out of it have
you seen it
this is just like drinking it
used you [ __ ] slobbered all over it
half the coffee's on the [ __ ] mud
have you seen this man drink yeah
he's like he's like he just doesn't know
where his mouth is
gone is like a like somebody like a
person who used to be a dog in like
another life but just never forgot how
to like
he drinks like his mouth are you kidding
me i would love to be a dog in my next
life or this current life dogs have like
the easiest [ __ ] lives in existence
dogs and cats you just you just do
nothing all day they piss [ __ ] and
unconditionally love that's what they do
right
that's what a dog is i watched i watched
have we had anything have we done our
intro yet oh no we haven't um hi this is
the intro joey's the host yes hello
sonic fans i'm joey welcome to trash
taste i'm with gone connor yeah episode
69 this is absolutely
more intro than that i uh i texted felix
uh earlier when we found out that this
was episode 69 because a little
backstory so uh you know felix would be
pewdiepie who we've been trying to get
on the show but can't come to japan
because you know obviously because of
the world situation so but we hoped that
oh yeah you know by episode 69 hopefully
you know he would have been able to come
yeah obviously he couldn't so uh i uh i
texted him and said i'm sorry man like
we didn't didn't he didn't he like
specifically say reserved episode 16. he
was like joey if you if i'm not on
episode 69 i'm just not coming on
because i remember you telling me that
in like episode two or three or
something just when trash taste started
yeah and i'm just like are we even going
to be around
69 like like are we even gonna have an
audience by then i was like well felix
you're very very like positive thinker
like thinking 65 episodes ahead i was
just like i could even like envision
episode 69 because i was just like i'll
be happy if we can last a year yeah
honestly honestly
it's weird to think that we're probably
going to reach 100 episodes that's scary
there's going to be like which episode
of trash taste this oh it's 179 actually
yeah right that's weird to think that
that could be a thing
scary because when i see joe rogan it's
like episode 800 or something yeah [ __ ]
but he doesn't he like record three
episodes a week or something yeah it's
it's like once every two days like holy
yeah like four hours long yeah yeah yeah
the man
[ __ ] i think i thought i'd run out of
topics to talk about yeah right oh my
god